in the heart of Mexico City is a school
exclusively for gifted children and at
the heart of that school is a gifted 16
year old prodigy named Daphne Amazon
Kiera Segura make a los ninos sobre
atados no sense criminal Osnes estan en
todas Parisi ADO's
[Music]
Daphne is a child prodigy who became the
world's youngest psychologist at the age
of 13 and Forbes magazine named her one
of Mexico's most powerful women at 14
she received her master's in education
and right now she is finishing a
doctorate in law as if that wasn't
enough
Daphne speaks English French Latin and
Mandarin and finds time during the day
to study them all did I say that she's
only 16 yes it is estimated that there
is over 1 million gifted children in
Mexico with a talent waiting to be
tapped so Daphne is committed to
nurturing the vast talent at the gifted
children of Mexico that's why she
teaches psychology at the school she
once graduated from Central the
attencion el talento MS for a
conventional Esmail como estas niñas an
mal agnostic ADO's contrast or no
deficit attention hyperactivity Jia muy
tarde mi clase pintura esta Cora porque
los ninos estan expresses an intern okay
now corresponds so stilettos yeah Matias
que están muy por debajo de sus
habilidades intellectuals yoy tarde my
class a a piano
Esther Brock aquellos Nino Sabourin de
éstos temes is a strallan Geritol
hammock message
[Music]
es por eso que canta mozcon um program
Amoy disciplinary Oh que se parte de por
maestro sobre atados for example there's
this science whiz kid who knows the
entire periodic table like the back of
his hand or this kid with a sharp memory
that allows him to memorize every bone
in the human body there is this
six-year-old kid presenting on an
interesting slope you repent you
livermorium ununseptium ununoctium yes
Rama your objective is to analogously
represent ice-cream escambia de mañana
de Henares en de siiva kadar sake para
Jabara Mexico por la vía very
progressive
[Music]